"The Expendables" movies were once massively
popular — so why are audiences treating the
fourth movie like it's, well, expendable? Here's
why "The Expendables 4" was a box office dud.
Let's address the biggest elephant in a
room full of them: "The Expendables 4"
performed badly because of its extremely poor
reception among critics. The film scored a bad
Rotten Tomatoes record, hitting an initial
rating of just 15% on the Tomatometer after
84 reviews. That number places it among
some of the worst-rated films of 2023,
such as "Fool's Paradise" and
"Winnie the Pooh: Blood and Honey."
Many critics have singled out "The Expendables
4" for having a barebones plot, poor performances
from the cast, and lackluster action sequences
cluttered with low-quality CGI. In its review,
Looper's sister site /Film gave
the movie a score of 3/10, writing,
"The characters are inhuman, the premise is
absurd, and the plot is idiotic. This is a
Saturday Morning cartoon with booze, f-bombs,
and a mild libido. It's staggeringly stupid."
According to Deadline, "The Expendables 4"
had a fairly small advertising budget of
just $20 million in the run-up to its debut. As
such, it's likely that the film completely flew
under the radar for many casual consumers who
otherwise might have been interested in seeing
it. Deadline further suggested that the lack
of advertising surrounding "The Expendables
4" was actually a conscious effort on the
part of the film's distributor Lionsgate,
as the company surmised that the movie
was not going to be received well.
To further complicate matters, the road to the
premiere of "The Expendables 4" took place amid
the 2023 SAG-AFTRA strike and the WGA strike.
So a lot of the film's cast couldn't promote
their projects during the strikes, as doing so
would constitute crossing the picket line. Thus,
"The Expendable 4" saw its release in
September with little to no fanfare.
If there was ever something that could be
remotely considered a zeitgeist surrounding
"The Expendables," it happened in the early
2010s. Back when these movies first released,
they built on each previous entry in quick
succession with more action-packed plots
and eye-popping cast additions.
That's why the nine-year wait for
"The Expendables 4" has made it
feel like it's late to the party.
The landscape of Hollywood looks quite different
compared to the last time "The Expendables"
reared its head. Streaming has changed the
way people watch movies, and companies need
to work harder than ever to provide convincing
reasons for audiences to head to the theater.
Rival franchises like "Fast and Furious" and
"Mission: Impossible" have grown even bigger,
filling the vacuum left by movies like the early
"Expendables" films. Audience tastes have shifted,
too. With superhero movie fatigue and
sequel/reboot exhaustion growing ever
more pertinent, the tolerance for a clunky
action movie revival is at an all-time low.
To say that "The Expendables" never
had a chance at seeing success after
such a long stint away from theater
screens isn't quite right. However,
if the franchise really wanted to stand out in
the modern day, it needed to grow past what it
once was and deliver something compelling.
Instead, "The Expendables 4" has slid in
the opposite direction, and failed to match the
spectacle and fun factor of the earlier films.
"Hey, why don't we have dinner?"
"Sure, when?"
"In a thousand years."
"Too soon."
If there's one thing big blockbuster action
movies are known for, it's their uncanny knack
for landing casts filled with recognizable
talent. "The Expendables 4" isn't a complete
slouch on this front, as it unites returning
franchise actors like Sylvester Stallone, Jason
Statham and Dolph Lundgren with new additions
like 50 Cent and Megan Fox. However, it's tough
to deny that its cast list pales in comparison
to the star-studded line-ups of previous entries,
which included massive names like Harrison
Ford, Arnold Schwarzenegger and Chuck Norris.
"Rumor has it you were dead?"
"Yeah, I heard that, too.
So how's life treating you?"
There's nothing inherently wrong with having
a movie cast that isn't completely stuffed
with huge A-list celebrities. However, "The
Expendables" has a legacy of doing just that,
and the star power behind this fourth entry in
the series feels weak compared to what has come
before. With few actors to draw general
audiences in on name recognition alone,
the film isn't as popular as it could have been.
Some would-be viewers may have also been put off
by a certain shift in dynamic among returning
stars for "The Expendables 4." While Stallone's
character, Barney Ross, has historically
been the face of the franchise, pre-release
information on the movie made it apparent that
he was passing the starring role over to Jason
Statham's Lee Christmas for this latest entry.
"Why are you here?"
"I got this situation where I need your help."
"I need better friends."
That's a change that may have rubbed
at least a few fans the wrong way.
There are a lot of problems with "The Expendables
4" that contributed to its box office failure,
but solely placing the blame on the
movie itself would unfairly ignore
the difficult path that "The Expendables
3" set up for it nearly a decade ago.
For those less familiar with the history of the
franchise, "The Expendables 4" is not the first
critical stinker in the saga. At the time of
its release in 2014, "The Expendables 3" was
similarly panned by critics for failing to
live up to the expectations set by the first
two movies. It stands to reason that some
fans who felt burned by "The Expendables 3"
may have written off "The Expendables 4" just
by virtue of the quality of its predecessor.
One also has to account for the fact that being
the fourth movie in a franchise can be a bit of a
tough sell. Some potential viewers might be under
the impression that watching previous entries
in the series is required in order to understand
what's happening in the newest film. Then, there's
the simple fact that sequels are risky commercial
territory for just about any franchise. Some
sequels fare better than the original in terms of
box office performance, but others can't manage
the same level of retention. "The Expendables
3" already had a lower box office gross than
"The Expendables 2." So "The Expendables
4" is just following that downward trend.